when I was a young man marketing for my
dad's liquor store and wine store if you
wanted to get people to know about you
you had to pay you had to
[Music]
pay I had to pay a newspaper to put an
advertising in the newspaper I had to
pay a cable company to run my TV
commercial I had to pay for a billboard
to show my sign I had to pay the
marketing uh Direct Mail company to make
a flyer and send it into your mailbox so
you would see it I had to pay
today the attention of the world lives
in
here the things that dominate here is
gaming and entertainment and social
networks people here complain
that they're not getting a lot of views
on their videos on Instagram or Tik Tok
or these platforms but they have
forgotten that it's
free let me say this nice and slow
today if you were to advertise on social
networks the cost of showing up not
making it but showing up is free this is
crazy Google which I used a lot Google
AdWords how many people here do Google
AdWords pretty aggressively for their
business a little higher I just want to
get a
sense a lot of you Google charges you
money when somebody
clicks not everybody converts you try to
figure out if the amount you pay do
enough people convert that it's worth
your money but it still costs you
money The Social Network Revolution is
insane it is free to build brand
most people in this room most people in
Brazil most people in South America most
people in the world do not produce
enough content for how big the
opportunity is for free
attention that is the biggest elephant
in this room
[Music]
today for you today what would be the
top three platforms to be on because
there are so many and what would you do
on each of them if if you were starting
now what would you do on Tik Tok YouTube
Instagram or Facebook yeah so I think
again back to the earlier point of
self-awareness if you're selling
B2B all of a sudden LinkedIn is number
one right if you're selling if you're a
sass if you started a SAS business if
you're listening right now and you want
to s or you you sell to lawyers you have
a service that sells to lawyers then
LinkedIn is going to be number one
globally for sure with YouTube shorts
probably being number two because
YouTube is a search engine yes and a lot
of people search there so that would
also be good if you were into SAS and
then probably in that scenario I would
then say if you're selling you know a
B2B service after those two probably
Facebook grounded in a Facebook group
with then Twitter X being probably
fourth if you're selling SAS Instagram's
probably a distant fifth Snapchat
Pinterest they're super far away in that
scenario if you're selling
t-shirts to 15 to 25 year olds all of a
sudden Tik Tok becomes number one
instagram probably becomes number two in
that scenario and YouTube shorts is
number three right so I think for a lot
of people that's that reality for
broader markets I think that if you're
really trying to sell something like to
the broad consumer call it for everybody
who's 25 to
55 well now you start getting into
Facebook still being an incredibly
powerful platform for selling MH um I do
think that organic Tik Tock for Branding
is exciting Instagram again becomes a
stronger selling platform but both of
those scenarios require ads more than
organic reach yeah um whereas Tik Tok
you can win on organic reach and kind of
capture lightning in a bottle so the you
know I hope everybody appreciates the
answer it it it is
contextual
now what's the importance of
diversifying your
content I love you for that clearly
maybe you've been you know I've been a
little bit loud about this last 60 days
I'm writing a new book next year it's
going to be called day trading attention
so I've been in it trying to teach
everybody how to win on every platform
Tik Tok YouTube cuz social media is the
current place where attention is if the
metaverse comes I'll be telling you what
to do in those [__] headsets I don't
care where attention is cable TV 20
years ago I'd be writing books like
cable TV
40 years ago regular TV regular TV 80
years ago radio how to hack radio I just
want to know where the attention is
Spotify rap cabar is important today it
used to be called TRL it used to be
called The Source it used to like I
don't hot 9 I don't give a [__] I'm
agnostic to what platform has the
attention I just want to figure out
where it is I want to be great at it I
don't hear social media I hear Tik Tock
and then I double click Tik Tock regular
post Tik Tock live different I don't
hear LinkedIn not just where you put
your resume no no I hear that's a social
network double click there's regular
posts there's video there's written word
there's pictures this is science it's
skill so diversifying content is the
number one reason that the person on the
other side of this video right now is
not popping off like she he wants to
people get stuck in ruts they got
something that worked for them or
they're comfortable with and they're
posting the same [__] they posted 5
years ago on in stagram even though a
ton of people are now on Tik Tok and
Instagram so there's less it's different
mhm and we've already seen all that [__]
from you and they get tired we all grew
up with [__] that was hot as [__] and
then three years later it was less hot
because we got it that's why Madonna was
a beast she was like oh I got you for
four years now I'm going to I'm A
Material Girl now let me go on a cross
and some D I'm going to do this and I'm
going to be Vogue and she just kept
mixing it the [__] up we understand and
by the way we see that all the time like
there's the people that have one pitch
and they're hot for three years and we
never heard about them again right and
then there's people that are [__]
icons why because they Diversified their
content that's
[Music]
major the best YouTubers in the world
starting with Mr Beast Down spend more
time and more money on their thumbnail
than you could ever imagine so number
one for everybody who's going to do
video
and again that's a whole another
conversation because for some people it
should be written word some people
should be doing audio some people should
be doing video but I think uh I think
the thumbnail on video is incredibly
important I think the first three
seconds thing that Dustin and I were
talking about on our trip this week is
do we need the hook from the from the
thumbnail to be delivered on in the
first two or three or 4 seconds and and
we we really believe we do we believe
that if if my hook says you know 30 to
40 year olds you should be thinking
about LinkedIn and if my opening line is
like before we get into that I you know
like you might in two seconds you may
lose that audience and so I think a lot
of science around the art I think a
couple of other things there's a lot of
ways to do it let me encourage some
people one thing that I've been noticing
is on Instagram you could just take a
photo of something right you were here
with your friend this weekend in New
York you could take a photo of like a
nice picture that caught your eye in New
York take a photo but if you then wrote
three paragraphs really great ones
because you're a great writer about the
concept of enjoying the weekends to
reset of the concept of busyness in
chaos in Controlled Chaos is an
effective way to be an
entrepreneur you could write the you
know curiosity I've been to New York
seven times but I've never gone down
this street right like you could take a
photo of anything a banana a car a tree
a bird your backyard it you really could
take a photo of almost anything and then
write three or four paragraphs that are
very thoughtful about a point you're
trying to make now all of a sudden you
don't need a video and editing
team you could do it all by yourself and
for a lot of people listening they're
not great on camera they're not great
with their words but they're incredible
writers and so it's around
self-awareness of the me the the style
the content and then there's strategy
around the distribution depending on
your business and so that's one main
theme to keep getting very nerdy and
deep on your question the other thing to
always look for is underpriced attention
yeah the thing that I know you know
about me over these last seven eight
years is that I have a very strong skill
set in understanding where there's more
organic reach against consumption
and and when to do it hard than most
people and that's been a big part of My
Success you were there when I was
yelling about musically and Tik Tok when
that when that seemed crazy to almost
everyone you you weren't there but
people that have been following me all
the way back to 2005 6 and 7even there
was in an incredible amount of content
and passion I had around YouTube and
Twitter and Facebook I mean I wrote
Crush in 2008 came out in 09 but I wrote
it in 2008 that's 15 years ago long time
so I I think that I constantly look for
the underpriced
attention it's always most exciting when
it comes up in a new platform but new
platforms only come around every 3 four
seven nine years yeah then when it's not
a platform it goes into the things we
just talked about the strategy within
the platforms yeah I talked about
recently it's already lost momentum in a
month but a month ago I was incredibly
excited about posting a meme and then a
video on Instagram a two poost Carousel
I saw that mhm and you know I I I see
incredible uh opportunity that again
almost talking to Dustin I'm almost
having my own meeting right now one
thing that continues to work for me is
taking headlines that are happening in
pop culture business and doing a green
screen and talking over it that model
continues to work better than if I just
looked in camera right now and talk and
even when the the green screen the Green
Screen Video is not great quality like
it doesn't look good but it it works
correct to your point my last one which
did really well I was in the car and the
light was hitting a different way and it
wasn't like my yeah I was like distorted
that's
[Music]
right
content I always said to myself do I got
content or I'm just document my journey
cuz I'm going to L this [__] whereever
you recorded or not so what's the
difference between content and
documenting the journey yeah there was a
moment there was a kid in here it was a
big moment for me it exploded for me we
were just chopping and I just cuz thank
God I was filming back there and I just
said he's like I don't know what to make
I said document don't create right
people have shoot days I'm an influencer
I'm on today I'm going to make stuff
that's commercials that's TV that's fine
by the way that works for a lot of
people people like you and me and a lot
of people out there we should be
documented mhm not creating right we
because what we do is just who we are
just you know the best [__] you ever
said the best [__] I ever said it's lost
I said some [__] to my sister the other
day I'm like [__] I wish that
[__] was fil you know like like it's so
the difference
is not a lot the key for everyone is to
be self-aware of who they are some
people this is what blew me away maybe
this hit you too as my life started
changing I started rubbing elbow with
different kind of people I'm like yo
some of these Comedians and actors like
suck in real
life but in the context of doing it for
film they're beasts and then then I did
enough TV and different [__] I'm like oh
this shit's slow you go do a movie
you're like all right back in the
trailer for 3 hours I'm like [__] this
[__] you know for other people we like
it raw clean authentic no [__] no
[__] with it like that works for us so
for everybody on the other side there's
two groups there's the people that
should do it the actors way like they
should make the studio proper they need
their not they they need to memorize
their lines and then there's us more
improv we're more SNL than we are
feature film right improv live life on
stage you know in the kitchen around a
dinner table chopping stoop life it's
that [__] and so cool like neither's
better the key is does everyone on the
other side of this know who they are and
are they trying to force
it
what is universally true for everyone in
this room regardless of where you are on
the journey within this industry is that
the far majority of individuals humans
here and companies are not taking
advantage of what's happening in
LinkedIn right now so just from a pure
practical standpoint there's so many
wants and dreams and hopes and things
that you want to happen in this room and
one of the most significant
opportunities to make that thing happen
is actually knowing how to make content
for LinkedIn and actually posting it and
actually reaping the benefits of it
LinkedIn right this second is acting
like a social network more similar to
what Facebook was in 2013 and 14 and the
land grab for B2B companies and B2B Toc
companies that I've watched over the
last two years grow and explode and
really I won't use the word exploit but
just so everybody understands no ads
just taking advantage of best practices
to create organic reach is
disproportionately the underpriced
attention the
underutilized move of this Collective
room you can literally make videos and
pictures and run $25 to 50 $100 on
LinkedIn against employees of venture
capital
firms and reach them and not have to go
to conferences and pray that you'll run
into them in the hallway to pitch them
your startup
and this is results tomorrow LinkedIn
content for your business you can
literally reach everyone everyone so
many people's agendas here today is to
do business development right you'll
listen to my talk but what you're
worried about is what's going to happen
out there and what's going to happen
tonight that's why you're here that's
the actual business the fact that I know
that scales 365 days a year if you spend
the 5 or 10 hours to do research on how
do I make good LinkedIn content by the
way there's an incredible website that
will tell you everything you should do I
know some of you are taking notes I'll
spell out the website for you g o o g
thank you for doing that that made my
[__]
warning you can literally type in how do
I make LinkedIn content for an insurance
SAS company enter and get obnoxious
amount of results with best practices
this isn't about when I talk about this
stuff they're like Gary but how do I do
it that's like saying how do I get into
shape everybody here knows how to get
into shape it's called stop eating
[__] and go to the
gym doing it is
hard I promise you that if every person
here leaves and does proper because
there's the right way to do push-ups
versus the wrong way does proper
LinkedIn content three times a
day that they would see miraculous
results for their business a year later
uh Taylor Swift yes Travis Kelce yes
have changed the NFL's business yes
without the NFL being a part of its plan
at all that's right like what is the
attention message from I know you're a
big NFL
fan like is there a message in that yes
of course there is it's actually one of
the biggest parts of the book which is
that everybody on Earth underestimates
pop culture what happened with Taylor
and Kelsey is they're cross-pollinating
their platforms M so if you're a
mechanic in Detroit like I said in this
post on social you're not thinking about
hitting up the Thai restaurant down the
street to do a piece of social media
content I know that's true today yet
that's the kind of left field post that
will get people's
attention and so what I see there is
what do I think about pop culture I
think it's one of the most significant
currencies on Earth what if you're lucky
enough to have an employee that works
for you that's first Nam is Travis and
another one that's first name is Taylor
like literally you're a law firm Travis
Johnson Taylor Smith maybe they're both
guys cuz Taylor is obviously a name that
can go either way you can easily use the
micro moment of the infatuation of our
society to do something clever and silly
what people don't realize is that little
clever video on Instagram that only got
90 views one of those 90 views is
someone who's actually considering to
hire an attorney and they actually like
the fact that you were a little silly
and not buttoned up and you made them
feel more comfortable to reach out to
you to work with your Law Firm or your
dentist's place or your like I people
are very linear they don't realize how
big pop culture is and how they can
factor into their boring business I had
a I had a um gentlemen reach out to me
who asks literally I used a concrete
cement business in one of my analogies
in a piece of content he literally owned
a asphalt business he literally started
to make Tik toks even though he thought
it was the wildest craziest thing he'd
ever heard and it literally has doubled
his business an
asphalt seller like guy that comes and
redo your driveway made a couple Tik
toks one went decent another one went
viral and literally if I recall properly
the email a business that was doing
$800,000 a year servicing a local area I
think he was in Wisconsin is now doing
2.5 Mill he he the tears were coming
through the
email but most people who are listening
to this podcast don't who are in a B2B
or like a different kind of business are
not thinking how Tik Tok can work for
them right and pop culture doesn't
necessarily mean that you need to have a
your celebrity endorser correct you're
you're playing off of what the
conversations that are going on it's
like being good at a cocktail party
right think of this as your social media
marketing you go out tonight and it's a
fundraiser of your local PTA or the
school or or it's the the banquet for
the high school basketball team are you
the kind of person that comes to that
event and you're enjoyable to talk to
and have a circle around you or are you
in the corner by yourself the reality is
being an introvert and not being
comfortable in that is incredibly
appropriate and awesome as a business
you'd like to think that you're trying
to Market and get business and so to me
there's so much more permission for
creativity Than People allow themselves
but you know like people continue to
like wear their suit and tie in their
LinkedIn profile and like they they they
don't understand the room is what I ALS
ultimately think I think like you take
the most stuffed up person you know
literally I want everyone to close their
eyes and just think about like the most
kind of buttoned up stuffy rigid person
you know I promise you if that person
goes to Las Vegas right now with their
best friends from college for a weekend
they're going to be a different version
of themselves than you know them and I
think businesses and brands have more
permission to be contextual to the room
they're Distributing the content in when
I make Facebook content I'm think think
about parents because I know the demo is
going to be older those are going to be
different videos that I'm putting into
Tik Tok where I know they're going to be
youngsters the words and the videos and
the slang and everything I say and do is
different yet I believe most people are
just making a video and then pushing
them out on these channels and expecting
for it to succeed they think of it as
distribution I think of it as a place
you have to be contextual to win the
[Music]
room I would just ask Maybe what would
be some advice that you have for someone
who's just starting off what are some
things maybe you've seen specific to the
fitness industry that have helped scale
and then maybe just in general
eventually I'd like to kind of grow my
own kind of personal brand be able to
down the road step away from the gym
kind of throw online amazing everything
I just heard and as you can imagine the
the there may not be a more cliche
stereotype than the fitness dude who
built a Fitness business on social and
then decided to teach everybody how to
build business to build a personal brand
you're like in my pocket the answer to
the question is you need to post 30
times a day on social media but you have
to be good at it so what you need to do
is what I just said about AI you need to
start googling and youtubing and
podcasting and educate yourself on
something I call sock strategic organic
content not just posting happy [__]
Wednesday and hoping it works like why
are you posting let me just pull it up
right now watch this it like this I'm
going into my phone I'm I'm going into
my content team
WhatsApp and apologize I need to run to
a meeting so I'm going to run out pretty
quickly here so I apologize I'm going to
scroll up here it
is here we go this morning at 7:21 a.m.
McKenzie on my team said good morning I
need you to post at 5:04 p.m. and 7:07
p.m. on Instagram one needs to be a
carousel one needs to be a
real this is called the science behind
the art I'm not out here posting
randomly for ha haa and my social media
strategy is not the
following all of yours
is I need you to understand the
thumbnail the first 3 seconds what time
you post how many words which platform
what's going on in LinkedIn carousels
that's different than Facebook par
Facebook reals What are broadcast
channels do you know what the [__] is
going on this is now the television and
until you understand that you are
leaving money on the
table back to scaring them this is how
it works brother right now everyone most
likely is just leaving double growth on
the table and then it becomes the thing
that puts them out of
business and so please take this serious
what you need to do how many times a day
do you post I it's nothing how many
probably once a probably once one post a
day and some days not even right yeah
some days not even even better about one
a day and flooding the stories and stuff
just Instagram think about where I am in
my career and where I want to go and
where you are you want to grow you're
your day one I shouldn't be the one in
this relationship posting 55 times a day
you understand yeah you will get
customers on LinkedIn you will get
customers on YouTube shorts you will get
customers on Snap Discovery you will get
customers on Pinterest and you're in the
best business you're in the visual
business take your shirt off and let's
go I got to go love
[Music]
you